TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
That's right.
Usually I say hello and
you say, Hi, Timothy.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I love that.
Welcome to Wearable
Computing with Google.
I'm going to try that
clicker one more time.
I'm going to switch
to the other.
Oh, something wasn't plugged in.
There we are.
Woo, when things work.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
You can reach me online,
google.com/+timothyjordan,
or on Twitter @TimothyJordan.
I'm going to cover three
topics in this session.
First, what is
wearable computing?
And I mean more than just
a device that you wear.
What is it at its core?
I'm going to talk about
how we live in a world
where users have
multiple devices.
They're using them
at the same time.
And instead of ignoring
that and letting
them compete for
each other, how do we
connect those devices together
into a single, seamless
experience for the user?
And I have an announcement
in that section
I think you're going to like.
And then third, how
can we use Google
to make this whole thing a lot
simpler and yet more powerful?
Sound like fun?
OK.
So first off, what is
wearable computing?
I keep having
these conversations
with developers about
cool ideas that they
have for new form factors and
wearable computing and beyond.
And although cool, they
aren't necessarily great user
experiences that solve
real user problems.
Let me give you an example, and
I hear this idea all the time.
In fact, a few of you probably
have had this as well.
Wouldn't it be cool if I walked
into a conference and everybody
I knew had a little
thought bubble above them
with their name and what
they do and how I know them?
It's not a great experience.
And I'm going to tell you why.
The user problem that
you're trying to solve for
is how do we connect people more
deeply to those around them.
And that's a great
problem to solve.
But in that solution,
what you end up
doing is distracting
them and distancing them
from the people around them.
Now, there's another
way to solve this.
What if the user
had that information
before walking into
a business meeting?
They could have looked
it up on their own.
What if it was just delivered
to them through their glass
or through their
Android Wear device?
That's a completely
different experience.
In fact, you can already
get it on MyGlass today.
And what it does is
it prepares that user
and gives them the opportunity
to connect deeply to the people
around them.
But the problem
with the first idea
is that it was built on
this idea of a device.
It was built on this idea of
what computing is supposed
to be in our future, when
instead, what we should
be focusing on is the user.
That's the true promise
of wearable computing.
See, people bring
technology into their lives
and wear it out into the
world on their adventures.
And our job is to enable them
to have richer experiences
and be more connected to the
people and world around them.
Let's take a step
back and examine
that idea in a little
bit more detail.
Computers used to
look like this.
They filled a whole room.
Shortly after that,
just on your desk.
And very soon after that,
the palm of your hands,
where you could get the full
repository of human knowledge
and worldwide
communication just right
there by reaching into your
pocket-- such a cool idea.
But something that you'll notice
about all of these devices
is without anything
else in the picture,
it's hard to see the human.
One of my favorite
thought experiments
is by this VR
pioneer Jaron Lanier.
Some of you have
heard this before.
Please bear with me if you have.
What if aliens came to earth--
cute fuzzy aliens-- and people
were nowhere to be found?
And they were trying
to figure out us
by looking at our computers.
What would they think?
Do we have 102 fingers
and one big eye?
No, we don't.
Now, if you look at a hammer,
it almost makes sense.
You could kind of
see the arm that
would wield that hammer
and hammer in nails.
But this computer-- I
mean, look at the keyboard.
It's not really built for us.
It's not even really
built to type fast.
Back when the keyboard
layout was designed,
it was designed to keep
us from typing too fast
so that the type bars
wouldn't get caught
amongst each other and
screw everything up.
But this is what evolved
into the modern keyboard.
This is a very
physical difference
between the person
and the machine.
Let's look at something that's
a little less physical but just
as dangerous.
What's wrong with this picture?
In many ways, this is our
relationship with technology.
It gives us a lot of value.
However, we are
adapting our lifestyle
to the technology
that assists us.
And there's a heavy cost,
and we pay it frequently.
How does that make sense?
What if we didn't have to?
Here's a photo I took a few
months ago of my team playing
a word guessing game.
That's Lindsay in the
top center of the photo,
and she's trying to describe
a word given to her on Glass.
What I love about this
photo is you can hardly
see the technology.
Some people think the
future of computing
is floating screens and
constant digital overlay,
constantly looking things
up on the internet.
They want to keep you
immersed and keep you away
from your life.
But as it turns out
with wearable computing,
less is more.
It's where we as
developers and designers
get to put the user
before the technology.
It's briefly there when you
need it, and not when you don't.
It gives you what you need,
and you're back to your life.
Now, this simple core
philosophy to wearable computing
is what you see over
and over and over again
in terms you hear
throughout Google
I/O, such as microinteraction
and glanceable information.
And it's not new.
It's the idea that
success isn't measured
by how long the user is
engaged with the interface
but how quickly we can
get them what they need
and get them on their way.
And there's a website
that's been around
for 15 years with that
exact philosophy in mind.
This kind of interaction
is in our DNA.
Back at the time when the
search engine philosophy was
keep the user on the
page as long as possible,
Google went in the
opposite direction.
And as it turns out, that's
exactly what users wanted.
It's exactly what they needed.
And that's why it
made sense for us
to recognize this
core philosophy
in wearable computing as well.
These devices are about
that kind of experience.
Now, that's not to
say that desktops,
laptops are going away.
They're not.
But those are often
tools for work,
whereas these are
tools for life.
That's what wearbale
computing is.
Now, let's talk about
connecting it all together.
Remember what I said?
What if the benefits
of technology
were available everywhere, no
matter what you were doing?
And this idea is bigger
than just one or two devices
that the user might have
on them at the time.
It's about all the technology
that they keep in their lives.
And this is what's meant by the
term "ubiquitous computing."
And it's how we need
to start thinking.
It's the idea that a user
starts to use a service,
and it's available to them
everywhere they want it to be.
Now, maybe it's something
as simple as an alarm clock,
but it rings in whatever
the context the users
enter right then.
And maybe it's in their pocket
or on their wrist or eyewear
or in the living
room or in their car.
And if you watch
closely, this is
where we as an
industry of wearables
is going-- connecting
all of these devices
into a single, seamless user
experience across all of them.
But how do we deal as
developers with the complexity
across this
constellation of devices?
Well, we do what any
good engineer would do,
and we simplify the problem.
We need two major
things-- that's it.
Platform components
that make it easy,
and a design pattern
that simplifies
the whole thing,
or maybe patterns.
Let's start with the platform.
Now, for Glass, you've
got the Mirror API,
which allows you to
insert timeline items
and have basic user interaction,
the GDK for full apps
on the device with
access to the hardware,
and advanced user interaction.
On Android Wear, you
can create a single app
with an APK that
runs on the phone
and on the watch as
well as notifications
going from the
phone to the watch,
including some enhancements.
Now, I told you I
had an announcement.
Glass is going to support
Android Wear Notifications.
[APPLAUSE]
This includes support for
enhanced notifications
in Stacks and Pages and Replies.
And it's going to be
available to users
on a build in the
next few months.
This is great news
for developers,
because it lowers the barrier of
entry into the wearable space.
You can build rich
notifications on the phone,
and they're delivered to
the user wherever they are,
whether that's the phone,
the watch, or Glass.
And of course, it's
great for these users.
Notifications will start
showing up on the wearable.
And as you may know,
to get this done,
you don't have to do anything.
They just show up.
Enhanced notifications will
also show on the wearable.
And again, to get this done,
you don't have to do anything.
It just works.
Now, Android Wear has
a few more features
for these notifications
that require just a few
more lines of code.
And they work on Glass just as
they would work on the watch,
with a couple differences.
Here's Stacks on Glass.
It's Bundles.
Here's Pages.
And of course, on
Glass, you're going
to have the Read More menu
items to get to those pages.
And of course, Replies.
They work the way you'd expect.
So that's platform--
Android wear on Glass,
bringing components
together to make
it easy to develop across
all of these devices.
Now let's talk about
a design platform
that simplifies the whole thing.
Let's go easy-- Model
View Controller.
I'm not kidding.
This is great.
Now, this is a simple
example of MVC.
And you can use any other
design pattern here.
But I'm going to show you how
to spread it across devices.
And it's a lot easier than
you might think it is.
But before I get there, who
here is familiar with Model View
Controller?
Interesting.
About 50%, evenly distributed.
You don't clump together.
That's nice.
So this is the MVC
you know and love.
Let's throw the user
in there as well.
For those of you that
didn't raise your hands,
this is how it works.
The view is what shows
the user what's going on.
That's what they see.
And maybe there's a button, and
the user touches that button.
That triggers the controller.
The controller
decides what to do.
And often this means
mutating some amount
of data in the model.
Then as that model updates,
the view gets that message,
and it updates in response,
so around in this circle.
Now, the view controller
part of this, that's
what your device is.
This is your watch,
or this is your Glass,
or this is your phone.
This is any device
in the user's life.
They're going to have a view.
We need to adapt
that per device.
And I'll talk more about that.
But it's got to be sticky.
You've got to remember
this part-- what
you design, the UI you
present to the user,
has got to make sense for
that piece of technology
that they're using.
And the controller, this
will be on the device.
And it also is sometimes
going to be spread across.
This might be in the
cloud in something
like App Engine,
where once they get
a response from each device,
it can hold on to that context
and deliver it back to
the user or to the view
through the model.
The model is the
required common layer
across all of these devices.
In fact, there's
two common layers--
it's the model and the user,
and they're platform agnostic.
They can use a number
of different tools
to accomplish the same task.
That's our goal here.
And we can use this
model, and maybe
the controller in
the cloud as well,
to keep context across
all of those devices
and deliver it to the right
device at the right time.
Does that make sense?
This is just the MVC
paradigm, except we're
stretching the
model and sometimes
the controller across devices.
So we're building a client for
the phone and for the watch
and for Glass.
But then we have
this other component
that's there to
help all of them.
Keeping that big
picture in mind is
what we're going to do
with an example-- building
all of these things on
top of Google technology.
We're going to make a reminder
app, because it's simple.
This is very simple.
I didn't spend a lot of
time designing these MOXs,
you'll see.
But the idea is
just to think about,
how do we put these
pieces together?
Because this is the
first time we're
really doing it at this scale.
And we're going to do
it on these devices.
We could, of course, add in the
living room or the user's car,
but we'll keep it
simple for now.
And these are our features.
The user is going to be able to
set a reminder from anywhere.
They'll be able to receive a
reminder wherever they are.
And it's going to
be location aware,
so they can set a place
reminder, not just a time.
Now, I'm not going to go
into detail here, but let
me just briefly go
over these items.
App Engine and Cloud
Endpoints, that's
what we're going to
use for our cloud.
There are two components you
need-- some sort of structure
that you can keep a
controller in if you need
to and some sort of
access to that model.
That's Cloud Endpoints.
I don't know if
you've used them,
but it's really easy to
deploy Endpoints right away
and be able to mutate
that model from any device
that the user might be on.
And then Android.
We're going to use
a lot of Android.
the Android Wear.
We're going to use the GDK.
We're going to use Geofencing.
And we're going to use GCM to
get information from the cloud
onto the device.
Now, here's our diagram.
I went for complex,
as you can see.
Again, this is a simple example.
But you can simplify this kind
of service across devices.
We've got App Engine
up at the top,
and then the user might
have any of those three
devices in the middle.
And of course, there at
the bottom, using them.
This is pretty much
the same diagram
that I showed you earlier.
But App Engine is the model,
and then each of these devices
has a view/controller pair.
Let's go through the feature
set, all three of them
one by one, just
to see how they're
built, how these pieces
are put together.
To set a reminder from
anywhere, we need first an app
on the device to
take the user input.
So we'll start with the phone.
And this is just going to
be a basic Android app.
It'll look a little
something like this.
I took my inspiration from
the alarm clock, as you see.
I can add a new
reminder with a name.
I can add a time for
that to happen at.
And of course, I save it,
and now it's on the list.
I forgot one of those items.
Oh well.
Now, there's a number
of steps involved
for that, because this
is a phone interface.
I can easily browse.
I can edit.
I can do lots of things.
But there's a number
of steps involved
in each one of those things.
And that's fine.
It's on our phone.
But for the app on the
watch and on Glass,
it's got to be simpler.
Remember, it's a device that's
microinteraction, glanceable.
I should be able to set an
alarm on the go and be done.
So for the watch, we're
going to use a voice command.
Just a simple one--
OK Google, remind me.
And I speak what I
want to be reminded.
And for Glass, OK Glass, remind
me to bring my speaker notes.
I did do that.
And finally, we need a common
place to keep all of this data.
And that's the App Engine
with Cloud Endpoints.
So any time the GDK app on
Glass or the Android Wear
app on the phone or on the
watch gets a new reminder,
they're going to hit
that Cloud Endpoint,
and it's going to
update our model.
And then that model is going to
sync down to the phone via GCM
so the phone always
has the latest alarms.
You're going to see
why, in a moment,
it's the phone that's
keeping the reminders.
To receive from anywhere, we're
going to use Android Wear.
This is the simplest part.
We want to let the user
know of the reminder.
We're going to send a
notification on the phone.
That's why it has all
the reminders on it.
And then it's going to appear
on the watch or Glass, whatever
the user has on them.
You dismiss on any
one of those devices,
and it dismisses everywhere.
One last step.
Just so you know that
you can add more pieces
and build onto this
basic functionality
is to make it location aware.
So when the user
sets the reminder,
we can give them an option
for a particular place.
Like, remember to get the bacon
salad, because it was awesome,
next time I'm here.
When the user sets
that reminder,
we'll give them that option.
And then the device is going
to pull GPS from somewhere.
The watch will pull it from
the phone and from Glass.
There's a location
service that is actually
pulling it from the phone.
So the phone is going
to keep the GPS.
And then it's also going
to hold the geofence.
So when the user enters
that geofence again,
then again it will
send out the reminder,
and it will propagate
to all the devices.
What I love about this example
is that each of these steps
seems like they're going to be
complex, but two slides later,
it's simple.
It's easy to do.
We can set from anywhere
by just having an APK
on each one of
these devices that
can accept the
data from the user
and send it up to the cloud.
We can receive
that from anywhere
by just sending a
notification on the phone
and relying on Android Wear
to get that to the user.
And it can be location aware
by just attaching some GPS
when we hit the Cloud
Endpoint with that reminder.
A few things to remember--
just a couple quick last notes.
First off-- this
is important, too.
We just talked about
building something.
We spent a lot of time thinking
about the design just now.
We would then go
into development.
We always kind of
hope that our time
looks like this-- lots
of time for development,
little bit of time for
debugging at the end.
You know as well
as I do, it usually
actually looks like this.
We need a lot of
time for debugging.
But on wearable devices,
you have a new piece
of that pie, which is
testing or UX iteration.
Now, you're probably doing
this a lot on your applications
already.
But if you're not or you're not
doing it much, for wearables,
be prepared for this to be a
large portion of your time.
And the reason is because
when you design the user
interface or a service that
goes across all these devices,
you have an idea of
how it will work.
But you don't know for
sure until you try it
while you're walking
across the street
or on the weekend at your
niece's birthday party.
You can't just test it
sitting down at your desk
in the middle of the work week.
And on the same note, or
a similar one at least,
these devices are
fundamentally different in how
the user uses them.
That's why you have to test.
We should also
think ahead of time,
know that you're
going to have to build
a different experience.
You can't just stamp out a
service from the phone on Glass
or on a watch and just have it
work the way you want it to.
You have to rethink
it a little bit.
What is it about the watch or
the Glass that you couldn't
do before that now you
can that will come alive
on these new devices?
We did not take the launcher
and just put it on the watch,
a bunch of icons.
That wouldn't make sense.
The user can ask for things,
or they can be given things.
This service should flow
from one device to the other,
because it's about the user's
experience across devices, not
just any one device.
Because at the end
of the day, we're
building for people, not
for technology-- people
out living their dreams
or having adventures.
And our job is to help them
have those adventures, only
richer, more fun.
We have some
documentation online.
Hope you check it out.
And of course, stay in
this room and stayed
tuned to this channel
for the next session,
designing for wearables.
I talked a lot about a
rather simple example,
just to describe how
the pieces fit together.
They're going to talk
more about the design
of each one of those pieces to
take them to the next level.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So, I do have some
time for questions.
In case I answered them
all, which would be OK, too.
But I believe there's
microphones around here.
There's a microphone stand
there with a droopy microphone,
but it's on there.
If you could go up there,
that way the people
watching the live stream can
hear your question as well.
That would be great.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
AUDIENCE: If you have Google
Glass and Android Wear
at the same time,
what authentication
would behave like?
So you'll get pinged on
both of them, or on the Wear
or on the Glass?
How are we are
expecting to do that?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
it's a great question.
I think we are all just
starting to explore this area.
So it's a rather simple
action right now,
is that if there's a
notification on the phone,
it gets sent to the
wearable devices as well.
And the nice thing about
the wearable devices
is it's a rather
subtle notification
that the user can easily
ignore-- just a buzz
on the wrist or a ding on Glass.
And when a notification
is dismissed
on any of those devices, it just
sort of goes away everywhere.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Question.
What about group notifications?
Say you go out hiking
or biking on a group,
and you want to notify the
group of a change of plans.
And they're all wearing
a watch, and some of them
are ahead of the pack.
Is there a group
notification functionality?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm a little
unclear what you're asking.
So you're saying you have
multiple users, multiple phones
and wear devices, and you want
a send a notification out to all
of them.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And maybe they're
using the same app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
So this is a great
example of using something
like that distributed MVC
model, only you're saving data
for the group,
not just the user.
So when you sync it back
down to the phone via GCM,
you're going to sync
data from that group,
and then all the phones
will be able to push out
the notification to
that particular user.
AUDIENCE: And
everybody will get it.
OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question more towards
the philosophy of wearables.
We design apps, and we do
design a lot of apps for Android
and things like that.
But the problem is,
these apps I don't
see being used by people who
are physically disabled--
or for example, a person who
walks in the road who is blind.
I don't think we are
teaching to that level still.
Although we have come
along way by building apps,
by building the app
store, et cetera,
now since we are just getting
started with variables,
how do we ensure that
we do build specifically
for this set of people?
How we as developers
can contribute,
and how, from your side, you can
ensure that this thing happens
and it reaches to people?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I
think what you're asking--
and stay at the mic
just for a moment
so I can be sure about this--
is it's really a distribution
question.
Once we build a
service-- and you're
saying in particular services
for disabled people--
how do we reach that
audience, because you're
having a challenge
reaching that audience?
And this isn't
really a new problem.
And I'm not an expert
on distribution,
so I don't know how much I'm
going to be able to help you.
But I would use your
app stores, and I
would evangelize with
those communities.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Tim,
for the presentation.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Question.
When we use Android Wear, we
send notification to our user,
right?
And they will see
that notification,
or they could see
the notification
in any device they have.
What if we want to
target a specific device?
Like, we have an app in
which it doesn't make sense
to send a notification to the
phone, but only to the watch.
And you don't want to send
notification to the Glass
as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
That's a great question.
So right now, Android Wear
sends the notification out
to whatever wearable
that the user is using.
So if they're using
multiple wearables,
it'll go to all of them.
The nice thing about
the notifications
is that they're
relatively easy to ignore,
so you can kind of
just pay attention
to where your attention is.
However, there are ways where
you can have a notification
just on a device
if that's really
important to your service and
you want to build it today.
Even in this example,
you've got a GDK app,
and you've got an APK
on the Android Wear
app that's on the watch.
And both of those can
communicate to the phone
and deliver
notifications to the user
directly rather than using
the Android Wear Notification
Service.
In that case, you'd be able to
choose which device you want
to have a notification
and which you don't.
AUDIENCE: Makes sense.
Second question, very quickly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Second question.
Yeah, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
So for Glass now, we have
initially the Mirror API,
then we have a GDK,
and now, happily, we're
going to have the Android Wear.
So are the three platforms or
the three ways of developing
apps are going to be available
for Glass in the future?
Or should we expect
to just focus
on Android Wear and
neglect the others?
What's going to be the preferred
way of developing for Glass?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So, I will give you
a general answer and
a specific answer--
and a general answer that
applies to this question.
Any other "what's going to
happen in the future" question,
as a policy, I don't
comment on anything
that might happen in the future.
There's some difficulty there.
But what I can tell you is
that the engineering and design
teams for both
Android Wear and Glass
work very closely
together, and our goal
is for all of this stuff to
work really well together.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What happens with
persistent notifications
on Wear?
Say, for instance,
you have a battery
notifier in your
notification bar
or some weather apps have
weather or what have you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I don't know
the answer to that offhand.
There is a more deeply
technical session
on Android Wear where you could
ask some specific questions
like that tomorrow, Android Wear
From A Developer's Perspective.
Or if you ask me
online later, I'll
look up the answer for you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Beyond
the basic interface,
what kind of
opportunities will there
be to fully customize
the screen for wearables?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
a great question.
So again, in this
example, it was simple.
However, the GDK
app-- and again,
the APK on the Android
Wear app for the watch--
are both code running
on the device.
And both allow you
to do full screen
UIs that are fully custom.
AUDIENCE: The new
devices for Android
Wear, they introduce new
possibilities of interaction.
So do you have anything
regarding gesture recognition?
So let's say, recognizing
the user is looking
at the watch or
something of that sort.
Lifting the arm
and looking at it,
or doing other types of
gestures with the hand.
Is that something that--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So there
is some of that built in.
And as you heard in
the keynote earlier,
that most of the APIs on Android
are also available for the app
that you build that
runs on the wearable.
So there's a lot of that
stuff that you can do already.
But stay tuned for some
more examples where
we can examine that
in more detail.
AUDIENCE: So, sort
of expanding on that
point, how do you see
gestures and voice recognition
working together or comingling
in a unified experience?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's a
great question as well.
It's interesting that--
and you should definitely
stay for the designing
section next.
They'll go into a little
bit more detail about this.
Different situations work well
for each of those instances.
Sometimes just being able to
say something really quick,
like remind me to, makes sense.
Trying to input that through
a gesture wouldn't make sense.
But then on the
other hand, you'll
notice when you
get a phone call,
just swiping across the screen
is really the right thing
to do for a watch.
On Glass you can do it through
gesture or through voice.
So in many ways, you're
giving the user the option.
And in other cases, there
is sort of a clear winner.
There are gotchas in each case.
So for example, if you're
using head gestures
and the user happens to
be walking somewhere,
there's certain head gestures
that work better than others.
So for example, looking
up and then looking down
works pretty good.
Trying to scroll a list
or scroll horizontally
would be more difficult.
So those are the kinds of
things you need to think about.
But all of those will
become apparent as soon
as you test it in
different situations.
AUDIENCE: And do you see
any implication or expansion
to context-aware gestures?
So you have
essentially a gesture
set to your specific location
or in your environment
so that those similar
movements mean different things
in different
scenarios or spaces?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think
that sounds very cool
and that you should definitely
explore that with the platform.
AUDIENCE: Come talk to me after.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Timothy.
Great talk.
Very excited about Android
Wear coming to Glass.
Question.
Up to this point, the timeline
has sort of been a chronology.
And the cards that are to
the left of the home screen
have sort of been
up-and-coming things.
So Android Wear
notifications, at least how
they've been shown
on watches, are
things that you see
once and then dismiss,
which is a little different than
the current paradigm for Glass
timeline cards.
They don't really get to dismiss
unless you actually go through
and delete them.
So I guess I'm wondering,
is this changing
the purpose of the
timeline in a way,
or how do you see that changing
or being the same in terms
of the interaction
with these cards?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
I'm going to give you
that same general answer before.
But again, two
more specific ones.
General, I can't
really talk about how
this is going to
change in the future.
The specific one
is the four guys
that are going to be on the
stage in the next session,
they're designers from teams
of both Android Wear and Glass.
They might have
some more insight.
Another specific
answer I'll give you
is that when you do
get an Android Wear
notification on
Glass, we'll always
include a Dismiss menu item.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Timothy.
I had a question.
You were talking about
the kind of maintaining
a similar experience
across different types
of wearable devices.
So with Glass and
upcoming with Wear,
we're working with both
gestures and voice control.
Do you see in the future
with the new wearable devices
those remaining the
predominant form of interaction
with your device,
or do you see maybe
in the future we might have
different ways of interacting
or focusing around
the same thing?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, if I'm
doing the hand wavy, what
do I think wearable
computing is all about,
I think all those
things are important.
I also think context
is really important--
where the user is, what
they're doing right now,
what they're doing next.
And sometimes
almost as important
as when they invoke
a voice command.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you very much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: After
Google Wear supports
Android Wear notification, is
Mirror API still supported?
And do you think they conflict?
Or is it still useful?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I don't think
any of these things conflict.
We're one big happy family.
And Mirror API is
certainly alive and well,
and there's Glassware
that I'm running
today that uses it that
I think is great for it.
For example, New York
Times uses the Mirror API.
So does CNN.
And just for sending a
timeline item to Glass,
it's really a
stellar experience.
How this stuff
evolves over time,
I can't really
speak to the future.
But we're always going to want
to make this stuff work better
and better with each other.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Tim.
First of all, awesome session.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: There are two
questions, actually.
The first one is the app
discovery in the wearable.
So like right now
in any phone, we
go and have the grids of apps.
So would the app discovery
be more context aware,
or like user can just still
go through maybe smaller
grids or different stuff or
have discovery in the wearable?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You know,
that's a really great question.
You saw that slide
where I had the Launcher
on the phone and the
Launcher on the Glass.
That doesn't make sense.
And both the Glass UX team
and the Android Wear team
went away from the Launcher,
like this post-grid philosophy,
if you will.
No grid icons.
When the user wants
to do something,
when they want to
start an action,
they use a voice command,
or they select that command
from the Voice
Command Touch menu.
And they're sort of given
contextually aware cards
about information
that makes sense
to them then and at that moment.
So you're exactly right that
the Launcher is going away.
And the base
philosophy in there is,
what if we could reduce
almost to nothing
the time between
intent and action?
A Launcher implies--
I take out something,
I look through stuff,
and I pick one.
Whereas when I say, OK
Glass, get directions
to the Museum of
Modern Art, it's done.
AUDIENCE: Right.
The reason of that question
was sometimes even on mobile,
you have so many apps.
So at one point, there
would be in Glassware too,
the user would have too many
things that they think useful
at times, but they
tend to forget, like,
was it already there?
So every time giving a single
command and browsing through,
it's kind of a pain.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And that's of
course against that philosophy
that I was talking
about earlier, which
is what if we can
make all this simpler?
What if we could give the user
all the value from technology
but with none of the fuss?
So I don't think our goal is
to fill the watch with lots
of different things
that they may someday
want to do, but to give
them the experiences
that they need to do today.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
And the second question
is-- for now, it's
more adding to the design
questions previous folks had--
there are guidelines
for Android app design,
like nav bar and six-pack
designs and stuff.
Is Android going to come
up with a suggested design?
And there are, of course,
anti-design patterns.
So are there any design
patterns to look forward
for the wearables?
Or as of now, developers and
designer have to figure it out?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Absolutely.
There are design guidelines
available for both Glass
and Android Wear, and you'll
find that they're very similar.
And they give you a
lot of information--
in fact, a very clear
road map of where
to go with your design.
So I'd look for that
on both the developer
documentation for each of those.
In fact, let me
back one slide just
so you can remember
what those URLs are.
If you add a slash design, I
think, to either one of these--
but I know for Glass-- they'll
take you to the design page.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks a lot.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: So I could
imagine many apps wanting
to implement wearable
notifications.
Is there going to be a central
place that a user can subscribe
and unsubscribe
to notifications,
or is it on a per-app basis?
And is there any way to
prioritize notifications
so that they get the most
important ones first?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
what will be available
when you get your
Android Wear device up
and running is that when
you have the companion
app on the phone, you can
choose any application
that you want to mute.
Certainly a lot further
we could go with there.
We'll just have to see
what the future holds.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Based on your example
for the reminder stuff,
if I don't have
the phone with me,
will it be able to create
an application that
uses only the wearable device
that holds information in it
and present or communicate
even with other devices
than the phone?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
a good question.
For the Android
Wear notifications,
that requires the
phone, because that's
where the notifications
are coming from.
But if you have the
Android Wear app, which
is an APK on the phone
and an APK on the watch,
that would work on the watch
even in absence of the phone.
And you'd want to build
your service in such a way
that you'd still have that
capability if you wanted it.
AUDIENCE: And connect the
watch with other devices
other than the phone?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I don't
know that offhand.
You'll have to stay
tuned for that.
AUDIENCE: From a
user's perspective,
it seems like there's a lot
of overlap and redundancy
in functionality
between Glass devices
and the Android Wear devices
that we've seen so far.
Is the expectation that
the user is typically
going to have one or the other,
or do we expect both of them
to kind of work together
in a lot of cases?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Gosh, I don't know.
I mean, we do a lot of building
these things for users,
but then we get to
learn how they're
going to use them
when they actually
get their hands on them.
So we're going to
have to find out.
I think with
wearable technology,
one of the things
that we start to learn
is once you do put the
human in that picture,
there's a lot of personal
preferences involved.
So we're just going to have
to see how that plays out.
AUDIENCE: Two quick questions.
The first, you had
talked about apps
on the wearable
communicating with the phone.
And there is
apparently structures
for that in Android Wear.
There's nothing like that
on Glass at the moment.
Can we expect or
request that sort
of data interchange platform?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So there is a way
for you to exchange
data over Bluetooth
between Glass and the phone--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: But you have
to roll your own, basically.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
It's not simple.
As far as the future, what
we'd release in the future,
of course I can't
comment on that.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Consider it a request, then.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: But I can say
that I've heard this feedback,
and I definitely
appreciate the feedback.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Second
very quick question.
What happened so your hat?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I left it.
AUDIENCE: I can't be
the only one wondering.
Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Some
days are hat days,
and some days are
hatless days, I suppose.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Notifications with
media style allow you to play
and pause things through
notifications like an app,
right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: I was
curious, is there
any limitation within the API
or anything that stops you
from building buttons
that do other things?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
a great question.
I don't know the answer offhand.
I'm sorry.
What I can tell you is
that when you play or pause
that notification on your phone,
it automatically just shows up
that way on the Wear device.
So if there is a way, then
that likely would as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a left eye version
of the Google Glass for people
who are weak in the right eye?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And this is
the last question that we have.
No.
Glass is only available
on the right eye version.
AUDIENCE: And there
is another question.
I don't want to carry my
phone around everywhere.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: I don't want to carry
the phone, the Android phone
everywhere.
I just want to carry my
watch and probably the Glass.
Is there a way things can
work with just these two?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
both those devices still
work in absence of a phone.
What doesn't work is
the notification service
which is relaying from the
phone to those devices.
So when the phone is not around,
it of course won't do that.
But again, remember that
on both these devices,
you can put APKs on them that
can run code on that device
and work in on offline mode.
So for example, with Glass,
one of my favorite Glassware
is Word Lens.
And it does translations
right in front of you
of whatever you're looking at.
And that works without
an internet connection
and without the
phone being present.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You're welcome.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
I really appreciate it.